Thank You Ignacio thank you Frank for
organizing this this event and so I am
accepting the challenge and now get a
talk on the board I think this it's not
a bad idea well laughs allow me to
explain a number of things maybe it
maybe it a smaller number and hopefully
a little bit better explain let's see so
um I'll really talk about symmetry
protected phases so let me put that
there invariance of symmetry protected
gap ground state phase
and I'll explain in what context and so
basically i'll give a little
introduction that explains what this
problem is about and why you may be
interested in looking at it then i will
say a few things that are very general
and sort of easy and apply to lots of
systems but you'd like to know more but
the more we can at the moment do for a
large class of system so i will then
focus on a specific case of frustration
free quantum spin chains with matrix
product round states of finally
correlated states as they are also known
and that will be a little bit more
specific and will involve a little bit
of computation i will see how far we get
so so first so so what a what is an
invariant but what what kind of
invariance would I like to study so in
this audience probably everybody knows
what the quantum spin hamiltonian is and
what the spectral gap refers to and what
the problem is of classifying gap ground
state phases and what quantum phase
transitions maybe but let me just make
this a little bit more specific so a
quantum physicist in the quantum space
system defined on the lattice and i will
often talk about an infinitely dress and
then find out subsets and it's not
important here so i will what this
ladders exactly is for instance maybe
your new dimensional hyper cubic lattice
it could be some it actually doesn't
have to be aleris some metric graph with
some decent properties but also
you but I don't necessarily when I talk
about a model Anzhi around Z she knew
and sometimes not to define it on a half
infinite chain so this is not the only
infinite set that will play an important
roles or something like this we will
also need to consider and then you start
by defining this model on finite volume
so if I write lambda it's always finite
finite subset of gamma and for such
subsets i can define the hamiltonian and
so you can have all kinds of terms but
in general i'm it's not worth in the
talk like this to spelling out the most
general conditions under which something
can be proved it would take a lot of
time so say finite range so maybe its
nearest neighbor maybe it has some other
terms and we will be understood in the
case that is Hamiltonian depends on a
parameter so these interaction terms
depend on parameter and si is in
interval 0 1 all right a real number so
that's the the Hamiltonian of the system
and and it acts on it so it's a
hermitian matrix acting on the Hilbert
space which I'm going to assume is
simply a tensor product of identical
Hilbert spaces also that is not
essential so we see all of these this
one is far away
they're all seen CD say finite
dimensional Hilbert space so so the gap
property I will assume throughout is
that the spectrum of H lambda the
submission matrix is a subset of the
union of two sets so there is an
interval which I will denote
suggestively easier or lambda of s this
is a typically the smallest eigenvalue
and then there is a delta lambda so this
is a short interval near the bottom of
the spectrum that contains the ground
state and maybe some states slightly
above it the idea is that I may want to
include states that as the system
increases also converts to ground States
you cannot exclude that and then there
is something of the form e 0 s lambda
plus gamma plus infinity so the Delta
Lambda Xander and the gammas are
positive numbers the delta lambda go to
0 as i go to my infant lattice if that's
the situation i'm considering that the
gamma is a positive constant and so
there is always for sufficiently large
fine at lambda a gap between this little
interval at the bottom and the rest of
the spectrum is separated finite
distance so that is and that's a uniform
in S&E the location of the ground state
we definitely depend on us but that gap
doesn't depend on us but at least there
is a lower bunk for it that doesn't
depend on us so that I'm going to call a
gap path all of this or a gap path of
hamiltonians
that s is sort of the path parameter so
that's the situation I want to talk
about well I mean there's certain things
i can do but if i want to i'm going to
be talking about Graham's it faces all
the time so if Delta Lambda doesn't go
to zero I make it in the limit states
that are ground states it depends but
you could are situations where it may be
useful actually to consider a delta that
is of order one if you have a specific
model where you know somehow that there
are excitations at the boundary dad in
size don't go to zero but eventually
that do not take you away from the
ground states you could consider it sort
of to be sure you're talking about
ground states i'm going to assume that
this Delta Lambda vanishes in the
thermodynamic limit so you don't require
that you go to 0 exponential past or its
own particular speed no not just be oh
yes and that covers a lot of cases now
so
I'm going to be interested in in the set
of all I call it will call them ground
States I don't want to consider the
situation where when certain for finite
lamp volume they said may include some
excitations but let's just assume lambda
is big another am talking about grants
it so I'm going to take denote by s the
set s that depends on those lambda n s
as the set of all states that i can make
density matrices that i can make
supported by I can factors with
eigenvalues in that bottom interval so
this belong to write better term so I'm
called I call that finite volume set of
all ground states so yeah all the
density matrices that are supported by I
can practice with energies in here with
eigenvalues in here I'm going to call
that set and then I'm going to be
interested in the week limits of that
set as lambda goes to gamma so then I'm
going to have another notation so when
lambda goes to gamma these converge who
another set and they are in general the
gamma will be infinite and this is the
set of all week limits
of states omega lambda and has numbers
so we limit means you take the
expectation for some fixed local
observable and a we take states for
which these expectations all converge
take a sequence of states for which
these expectations or convergence things
always exist and i denote that set by as
gamma is that i don't need to explain it
any further perfect all right weak
limits just the expectation values
converge so ah you are about the size of
a system you i'll just select a sequence
of a size will take the summer right
right and so sure but any any sequence
that is increasing and eventually
absorbs any finite subset of gamma will
do and taking different sequences may
give you different limits and all these
limits are included in the set i think
okay so you can take different sequences
of lambdas and for each flam that you
may pick a state in here and the only
requirement is that it converges to
something well defined as a functional
on the algebra of absorbance and these
are all my ground states for the
influent system so now so what's an
invariant so the basically in a variant
has a quality that I can associate with
these states that will be constant along
the curves that will be independent this
parameter if I have a gap path and and
the idea is that as long as I have the
open gap I'm in the same gap ground
state phase but it's interesting that
the system depending on a parameter
doesn't have oh you know it may be of
the extend the range of the parameter or
for other other models they get me
actually vanished
this uniform lower bound may may vanish
somewhere for the value of s and that's
where I see quantum phase transitions
and so the role of invariance is to help
you detect quantum phase transitions
it's a necessary condition for a quantum
phase transition to occur that the gap
vanishes in principle as possible get
banish you don't really have a
transition genetics exam States well I'm
going to so there is a there is a
question of whether you can reverse
implications but this is the definition
i will use so if i have this and in the
situation i'm talking about like
restoration free models this immediately
implies there's a gap for the gns ml
tonian in before the internet system
it's a nice salvage and operator with
spectrum that has a gap and the ground
state may be degenerate that's a
different that's a different issue that
doesn't mean that is there isn't a gap
sometimes I we find indeed the jealousy
of the ground state and there's
different kinds of degeneracy and that
the jealousy will often depend on the
choice of the end for Gladys I take I
take an infinite chain including both
their actions they will be different in
general then if I take a chain that goes
to infinity in only one direction but
that's an important that's an important
thing to use in fact yes well for all
four types of phase transitions for
which you have something like an order
parameter parameter then it's easy to
satisfy you know if there's there are
many sufficient conditions but whether
it is a run global sufficient condition
I don't know if your sanity dating
versus no symmetry breaking well that's
that's a sufficient condition so okay
so these invariants they they can change
in value only at quantum phase
transitions and so and the point is and
this this can be interesting because if
you if you started studying the gap is
not necessarily an easy problem so you
may study gamma the real gap or a bound
for it you can do it numerically maybe
maybe there is a critical point here
that if you do numerical calculations
you may see something like this you can
compute some values you can compute some
values here it looks like it's going to
vanish somewhere but how do you know it
really van is actually the problem of
computing it becomes usually more
complicated as the gap becomes small and
so you may want to have another tool to
tell you that in fact it does vanish and
in an invariant to do that because if
you can compute an impasse here and then
in value there and has a different value
then by the fact that it's an ovarian it
will imply that the gap vanishes at
least at one point in them in between
that's that's the idea of invalids okay
so and you can ask the question where
you can find enough invariance to
actually obtain equivalent conditions
and there's some ongoing work about
about this Bachmann in and or gotta have
some results on that I won't talk about
that I think you see Coco Gotham maybe
in the audience I think she was going to
be here so maybe you can ask her but I
will only talk about one implication so
if give the in back if there is an
invariant that takes different values
then you have a quantum facilitation ok
I'm going to talk about this this
implication and there is a what I'm
going to say next is mostly based on
joint work this time Batman who is now
in Munich LMU and it's in a paper in Jon
Lester school physics 2014 it's the
herbage phone special issue that you can
find it on the archive everywhere okay
yes well there's lots of things it could
certainly be interpreted as a level
crossings in some ways but there's lots
of things that we don't know about in
general contemplation sensations that
are some that understood because they
can be related to two models week we can
either we can solve exactly or they can
be be modeled by something we know you
know much better in general we don't
know very much okay I think we don't
know in general for instance that the
gap is a continuous function of such a
parameter I'm going to assume I didn't
say that these are always differentiable
functions of the parameter today I CD I
have to say something obviously
otherwise it doesn't make any sense man
say but that continues is probably
enough but in some of the proofs we use
derivatives okay so so what about the
the general stuff some
you can say general properties of gap
pass and the associated grant states so
this is sort of the soft stuff credit
it's sort of important to start with
that and that is it's basically than the
notion of Baltimore two equivalents
that's what we call it maybe it's not a
very beautiful name so yes yeah I didn't
get understood what's exactly the
invariant is well I want to find them
but it's it should be an object the
mathematical object such as a dimension
say that i can calculate based on the
information about the ground state
number one and it should be kind of
constant along gap pairs of Hamiltonian
okay at the ground states along one of
these gas paths it should be constant so
if it's a dimension and insert that
integer should be constant and then to
be to use it as if you if you compute it
in two points and you find the different
constant then you know something happens
in between right you have cross the
phase transition and the gap closed
somewhere in between but I told you what
they are so I'm going to get there okay
so so this is a i'm going to now
immediately assume that i have a
continuous symmetry in fact for the
first part I don't need to assume that
the symmetry is continuously so let's
suppose that we have a gap path
the local simony G and it's okay to
always think about just spin su 2
invariance of the other spin model
something like that if that's what
you're familiar with some of these
things are more general so in its a
local symmetry so it means that acts on
each of the individual Hilbert spaces
i'm going to say by some fixed
representation so so there are so there
are unitary is ug that represent the
symmetry these are d by d unitary
matrices and the act on the CD on the
space of a single spin and then by
tensor product a tax on the whole system
and assembly means that all these terms
so if i take the tensor product of these
unity Ariz or X in X then that commutes
with the all the terms that enter in the
Hamilton that's a local symmetry so for
instance I don't know if if you know the
LT model it's a good example to think
about basically everything what I'm
going to say so maybe maybe I'll briefly
put it here you can see chain so d is
equal to 3 it's a spin 1 chain and its
nearest neighbor so it's in one
dimension so the it would be defined for
it for a lambda of the form of a 10 in
finite volume and then it's a
nearest-neighbor interaction
I want me to write it is as the spin to
projection found 10 separate of two
spins so there is five dimensional space
of states that is get an energy one and
then the rest of energy zero the kernel
of this is four-dimensional for every
finite volume and so there are we are in
a simple situation where you can take
this to be one point if you want zero
there will be a four-dimensional icon
space of the eigenvalue zero and then
you have the situation where you have a
gap and the rest of the spectrum is
separated and it's money this could be
one point in some of these curves and
the symmetry is is as you too in this
case and it's implemented by the spin
one representation teeny dimensional
irreducible representation of su 2 ok so
so then when you have all this then the
that exist unit aires
which I'll denote by V lambda s and and
there are sometimes called the quiz I
adiabatic evolution of sometimes
spectral flow based on ideas of Hastings
Hastings tells us it is going to be
unitary is that that map the ground
state space of the different values and
eternium different values of parameter
into each other so if i take vectors c
lambda as how they always be able to
write them pass some unit fix unitary
transformation I can see 0 and these
unitary our queens are local I mean
that's the essential point because
otherwise there's no information in the
fact that there exists unitary since I
have these are all matrices as long as
the volume is finite and if the spectrum
is separated like that then the
dimension of this piece cannot change
that's clear and therefore can always be
transformed by unitary from velvet value
today that's not that's not that's not
special at all but what especially is
that these unit theories can be
constructed sort of in a consistent way
for all sizes and they have a quasar
local structure and then so want me to
save exactly what that is we're not
going to go into detail is that they
satisfy some kind of leap robinson bound
if you know that or i can also say
something else you can think of them as
as a solution of some dynamics for a
finite range interaction and that is our
order or short things interaction and
this phase a locality property will
guarantee that you can take the
thermodynamic limit of the action of
this unit aries on the algebra of
observers yes Larry McCoy guilty your
parameter s what is it was it s
I said this would be one point in some
curve right there's no parameter in it
there's no plan yes I'm from the whole
boy and satisfy the leadoff spot but it
was loco but also in general I cannot
prove it like that but if you start from
local hamiltonians that satisfies some
exponential bound on the range of the
interactions I can get tweezer locals
that satisfy about that is almost
exponential that in terms of just
strongly problems on Tony plums in that
I cannot and I don't know whether that
that would be true but for all practical
purposes you have enough locality for
most models you want to consider
question yes there is no in the exists
of unitary is the cemetery plays no role
but it comes in a second so I'm going to
focus on that on that case and you'll
see immunity where it where it comes in
but let me first and take the term and
I'm a climate of the action of these
unit Aires and so so the beta goes is i
define i think i can say is that show up
and so alpha s of a is equal to the
limit lambda going to gamma of the
lambda s start
s for all local observance a local
observables something that involves only
a finite number of spins okay this will
exist and it will be nice autumn or
pheasant that'll satisfy any problems
and bounds and for some other technical
subjects in need of it i'm not going to
need it here and this so this autumn or
fizzle will also map the ground states
into the ground states but i can now do
this for these week limits and if i have
the same at VG it will commute with the
symmetry g so i can take rotate is saved
and transform it i look at the same
result if I just transform it and then
rotate so let me let me write this
formally maybe I should write a hero so
the ground states that parameter s can
be obtained by compose with the
automorphism all the states the
parameter 0 so this is some sort of
local transformation and the observables
and so the ground state of one model are
really only locally different if you
want from the ground states at parameter
s under these conditions and the alphas
commute so that means the following so I
can take this alpha s of an observable
that I have conjugated with the unitary
all right so there is a corresponding
symmetry transformation let's call it
tau G of a
you still G many as many times as you
need Eugene and commuting means what you
think it means now you get the same
result like this and this now combined
with the fact that the alphas math and
to the states give you the fact
immediate fact that the action of the
cemetery on the states at parameter
value equal to zero and parameter value
equal to s are equivalent but this alpha
is a linear map it's an invertible
linear map and so these representations
are equivalent so the the action of the
symmetry g on and this thing is
equivalent is by an equivalent
representation
to the 1 i'm not writing a lot of
formulas and specifically because the
different ways you can look at this you
can look at the pure state so you can
look at the con of the convex hull of
all the states i get different
representations but if you do the same
thing for the different valves the
parameter that you get equivalent
representations so in the example and so
to use the example we need to choose a
gamma if i take gamma to be the infinite
chain and there's really not much
interesting to say because this model
happens to have terminal imitating Quran
states that are just exactly one pure
state so as gamma for the akhil team of
the gamma is equal to the infinite chain
it's just one point and they're not much
symmetry to do I mean of course it's
invariant in the disseminate but there's
nothing much going on but if you take
our to be the happens in the chain we
take it one plus infinity then and you
get a two-dimensional space of ceramic
limits then as gamma for de que el tema
a kelty chain I can write it like this
maybe is the state space
of of c2 or the spin one half so this
whole state if you take all the contacts
Holly it's just a block sphere of all
the states of a spin one half value and
so so for the finite chain in this model
of course you have for rest that's like
so you're saying somehow it reduces to 2
when you take the limit does respond to
understand that in terms of weak limits
or something how does that happen right
so so when you take the right boundary
to infinity and at finite distance there
is a spin one half type structure
sitting there but its influence to the
place where you put your observable
decays exponentially fast to the
distance and you take the limit and
there is no effect of the right boundary
commission the left boundary condition
on the other hand stays at finer
distance and still makes a difference
and you get a two-dimensional state
space of ground states clearly how the
dimension of the space of states changes
if I think you've done is pure States it
does it's not a continuous thing that's
right good i mention of that if you want
the pure States is not continuous in the
week limits that's that's correct and
certainly the convergence couldn't be a
normal any one of the storage ways that
states could converge it's only recover
so isn't it sorry to keep going on but
this is important that you work with
density matrices to take the limit and
then you extract pure states in some
cases it is indeed important because
because that's the other thing the limit
of pure States doesn't have to be pure
state so you can get limits in the week
limiting process that are non più states
in some cases so yeah that is exactly so
d examples of that so in this sense a it
is important okay
so so for the alt model I would have
then this action of the symmetry and
body ache a female in the Indy on the
heavens in the chain would then then d
if you look at the pure States it would
be a spin one half of the presentation
if you look at the density matrices it
would be the adjoint representation of
that which would be we'd have a singlet
and triplet in it okay and if an hour to
embed the akt chain in a gap path of
Hamiltonians that property would have to
be preserved and we believe for instance
that the standard pin one anti
ferromagnetic Heisenberg chain is in the
same phase and has the same property so
what I'm saying is that if you look at
the ground states of that model on a
half infinite chain you will find
basically a two-dimensional space of
pure States if you want to find the spin
one half the statements of a spin one
half with the action of this pillow and
have representation on it yes what will
you call the invalid then but is that
what do you go to exile it's coming
right spin one yes absolutely so okay
but there is already ended variant here
if you want so if you have in this
abstract setting which is the nature of
this representation it is for instance
to find it in the aquel teaching I had
to go to Athens in a chain head that is
one from the one and natural from the
other hand not so satisfying it would be
better if I could calculate something in
the bound doing observables so you can
accumulate statistics take some local
observable and and measure it or compute
it in the bulk and and detect invariant
that would be more useful so that's what
sort of the rest of the talk will be
about but if you wish there is an
environment here that is the nature of
the representation the action of the
symmetry group on the model defined on
the half infinite chain which in fact
you can generalize to any gamma you can
take half plane so you can take lattices
on a surface with non trip
topology and in general so there will be
an action of the cemetery if the
cemetery is not broken and the action
will be by a representation that doesn't
change up two equivalents as you vary
the parameter s so that's if you want
the environment but now i want to sort
of go a step further and show that in
some cases this environment can be
detected in the dock that is i can take
a ground state of the terminal plymouth
of the a kelpie chain for instance on
the x in a chain and do calculation
point gonna die so that app question now
I see in your eyes you don't believe me
but ok so let me see they release now
we're lookin a little bit so i have to
i'm going to use the final it finitely
coordinated state formulism so i
probably need to put a few things on the
board about that to explain what i'm
going to do do we have a clock all right
Oh written okay
so so there are two situations where
where I can show that the nature of this
representation is detectable in the bulk
and ads for spin chains either had as
precision three I have matrix product
ground States another class is about
which I won't say anything but it's a
similarly interesting class of models
that is disjoint from the MPS class
which is one for which you can in
space-time have a random loop
representation with positive measures
and and that sort of interesting because
some spin one half bottles fall in this
case and the positive measure is
important so you can use for the
ballistic arguments which I'm not going
to marry and essentially it's a closet
with the same result holds although it's
sort of this joint off of the MP has
class so and you can continue to think
about su term but I did I really want to
talk about you can take G just a
connected compact lee/globe it's
continuous symmetry let's say thank as
you do and I'm going to have frustration
free spin chains so in one dimension the
MPS grunts it's
and I'm going to quickly sort of review
some aspects that we will that we will
use a final ecology the final de
coordinate state formalism I think works
really well for the kind of things we
want to do here so let me recall a few
things so we have these the symmetries
ug the D dimensional representation of
our symmetry and say we have a
nearest-neighbor interaction but it
doesn't really matter its nearest
neighbor and that's focus let's focus on
the situation where we have a unique
ground state and determine our climate
and then you can sort of think what
happens if you have multiple ground
state some symmetry discrete sim at
least maybe they're a broken things like
effort you can sort of work it out
starting from from the basic result so
we have this is ug symmetric
you need ground state which of course
will automatically be a pure state in
that case of of the MPS form and it will
tell you exactly what that means so so
in it what it means is that things I
worked out a long time ago with my
father said line at banner there will be
an isometry V that Enterprise this
representation with another
representation or maybe as you start by
saying that there is another
representation and they call it little
little YouTube and you can as well think
about as you two and then isometry d and
this one the dimension let's do it like
this same here and MK k-dimensional
and in a sonically that embeds ck and
CDs answer ck and intertwining
representation so you GV u GG should
switch to a different pen yeah sorry
okay let's see this one already tight is
not very good let's say ug so in the a
Celtic is capital u ji was a spin
monitor presentation three dimension
little DG but gets a spin one half at a
presentation two dimensional so the V
embeds this spin one half a
representation in the stance of product
which decomposes in the spin one half
representation in this pin 1 plus a half
three have risen so this is this V in
this case if the representations are are
reducible representation of ask you to
for instance will be unique but in
general it could be non-unique that's
not important here but it does has this
intertwining property so this is this is
d this is K this is k ok so it's D K
times K matrix so are the FPS
aficionados this V if you write as a
matrix is the column of matrices that
they find your matrix products this
these are K by K analysis and you put
them in a column that's the that's the V
but that sense the cemetery part of the
point here it's sort of more convenient
to actually work with it with the V so
then so I'm going to describe now how to
state this pure state is defined in
terms of these objects and so for that
it's a convenient to introduce the
following labs so that every a and M D
that is a one spin observable we defined
a map e sub a of d which is V Star he
turns will be
G for all the and MK so you can counter
dimensions it works this this is a a
nice map from and k2 MK that depends on
a d-dimensional matrix also linearly you
can also think of it as a map of md
tensile and k2 MK and then so let me so
the relation to the state is so the so
the dispute state is unique ground state
that we are talking about here
on a simple 10 set of observable so if
you take take AI and md they kind of
them tensor product so that expectation
will be essential part of it is
composition of the maps e a this is
composition of maps and acting on the
identity taking the trace where the
density matrix row and that gives you
the unique pure state and so I'm going
to use these kind of things and this
let's see
my god leave the AKO teaching there for
just another minute so now i'm so what
we know in this situation is that e sub
1 which in the nba's language is called
the double pencil I'm has a the disk
conditions a spectrum that looks it's
complex numbers is contained in the unit
circle one is an eigenvalue but as the
only by I can value on the unit circle
all the other eigenvalues are here and
maybe there's an eigenvalue hear me
maybe not so but there's a sort of a gap
in the spectrum there's this lambda 0 1
and and one is simple as an eigenvalue
and of course the eigenvector is the
identity because this is v star V and V
was an isometry and so the identity is
always an eigenvector of this map but
the important thing is that we have this
trivial we're full spectrum so there's
just a simple eigenvalue 1 there and
that implies that if you iterate the map
it will converge exponentially fast to a
rank one operated so they iterate this
map I will go to write I get back the
left eigenvector exponentially fast and
the left eigenvector have is a
cavitation to be a density matrix follow
us on the general fear is a completely
positive map so it has a positive eigen
vector and then so it's also a simple
eigenvalue okay and so so what that
means is that phrase row e 1 B is Trace
roby for all the NN k and if you are the
situation here with the symmetry you
will you will have that row row
asymmetric it will commute the little ug
ranji because of its uniqueness this is
easy to check so the important thing is
from the purity of the of the state it
follows I have the simple eigen value
and have these exponential convergence
okay so and just putting a few things on
the board that will explain why we can
calculate this in value in the bulk so
the environment talking about is the
action of the symmetry the nature of the
representation of the cemetery on the
ground states of a half infinite chain
that I have to somehow see this in an
infinite chain so so you don't we will
need this map and we will also need two
maps eug which you think about it for a
second and play around with these
relations is actually similar to e1 has
the same spectrum and it has also a
triple peripheral spectrum and but now
so this is AG in fact that is little ug
and the eigenvector of the transpose so
this is a similar relation if you want
is Rho u ji start
it's only if you guys to check on to
that but in the interest of time maybe I
should move on these are the simple
relations that follow from the
intertwining relation of V but since it
also a stable political spectrum I will
also have that if i iterate this map
able converts to another rank one update
it so this is now capital you g-get
elated so that will converge to ride
eigenvector left eigen duck
exponentially fast okay so so why are
these properties important because of
what I'm going to do next which is
really a calculation in in the gns
representation of the state but the
essential part is just a convergence of
expectation values so I'm going to try
to explain it like that but I'll tell
you what it but it sort of implies so
basically what I'm claiming is that he
can give a good definition of the action
of the symmetry but acting only on half
the chain but not a half chain half of
an infinity so I'm going to want to have
the intimacy and I want to act with an
infant tensor products of unit Ares
starting here so you g and so you g
until you g and this is a well that's
not obvious that something like this is
well defined it has to do with the fact
that the simile isn't broken but also
with the fluctuations in this in the
state if if you have an invalid state
when it is invalid if i do tensor
product infinite in both directions then
there is a general theorem that says
that such a unitary representation of
the symmetry exists on Dean the J last
page of the Internet state but I don't
the state is not symmetric is not
invariant under the action of this unit
is so people worry i don't i don't know
that and in a way the existence of this
i'm going to call so i want to call this
and their proof that it exists you + g
is if it's going to be a nice strongly
continuous representation nice unit
carries its only equivalent to
the existence of an infant some of the
generators so these are 16 matrices on X
and I want to serve an entrant number
spin matrices from X to plus infinity
right then ug is of the form e to the IG
s say and SS places the mission ethics
they spin spin matrix so so normally if
you have an input something like this
even if there's no wrong is although you
may be worried that that this doesn't
fluctuate too much and this may not
exist but we will prove that it existed
in this case I will actually go to the
unit Aries and the way to do it is by
introducing a cut-off function that
looks like this half out so so i can
think of g as a sort of identify group
element and ezreal parameters so you can
think of it the angle so I'm going to
make a tensor product that that on the
left here rotates over G by then
gradually fades away and becomes the
identity so so this kind of function is
something like this form so it's going
to 14 outsides and then it's going to be
1 minus 1 over L minus 2 etc and then
eventually it will go to 0 and hows
great ok and you will immediately
understand by this choice has to do with
it the fact that I want to use these
properties so then i can define a s plus
L is sort of the evaded son no
i can write plus infinity good i'm going
to put f there so it really only goes to
now squared he'll think it's convenient
to put this and then you plus out of g
is just e to the i G as per cell so this
is a starting with non rotation and
rotation of very small angle then I
gradually increase the angle so the
claim is that you can compute first to
leak limit and then some technical stuff
let's do you conclude that there's
actually strong limits of this to the
object that I want and so so I'm going
to formulate that as a theorem and sort
of avoid the language of of the gnite
space so take some finite fixed and take
observables and the algebra so
observables of- and ends all right to
that isomorphic to MV 2 n plus 1 and I'm
going to look at the the expectation of
a light like like so will be meaningful
for some people so i'm going to switch
this operator between two arbitrary
observables that's equivalent to taking
matrix elements the doctors in the genus
hilbert space then i can take the limit
and i'm claiming it converges and
converge something really beautiful i
have a formula for the limit it is this
map
he iterated I will explain what that is
and then I have a bunch of ones then I
have been shown euros then I pin 2 and
apply this to little ug and it's all
about the little ug so let me try to so
capital is our observables for the spin
chain so melty spring absorbers but with
a fixed number of spins they are
localized in the end of all my
assignment so if i have something like
this in iteration so this is the sort of
linear extension of the iteration of
maps a bond say a.m so is tensor product
of n factors i can hit the latest maps
then i can actually also linearly extend
that because all these maps depends
linearly on a and that's this notation
so so this is a observable that the way
it's written there is not a tensor
product so i can't really decompose it
but i'm doing what i would have to do to
compute this expectation value giving
the final rated states formula for
correlation functions but the difference
is that if i put in the middle where the
U plus G instead of the formula appeal
with the one on the right hand side I
get little ug i get this representation
of the symmetry as the right boundary
condition so that's as the what's
important about this former
and the rest is just a notation of it's
really the same formula but i have put
little u jeediyey on the right time so
that's how the these rotations then act
on the right infinite chain so I follow
some from general nonsense that this is
going to be a nice representation of the
group and and it has all the properties
you want okay so now it's time to sort
of see what it means so let's take a
observables a1 and a2 that are located
here so perhaps so I have my unit that
is there then a p1 and into here alright
so the act on the left and i'm going to
think of the space of states that i get
so so first thing that you g is not
there to have this state of the bind in
a chain and I act with arbitrary
observables on the left side you can
think of this as boundary conditions or
conditionings or whatever on the left
and what you're going to get because of
the precision view properties obvious
its ground state some of the Hamiltonian
on the right because there I haven't put
any observables the on the toilet will
select at zero and so um so I'm going to
call this I'm going to take of this as
the action of you plus G on ground seeds
on the right half of the chain but they
are not have to it's just all the
backers that I get by perturbing the
original unique ground state by
operators on the left that's a nice
space in which the cemetery acts and end
it's invaluable to this so you can you
can prove that because this acts on the
other and the Hilbert space it the
mountain proving that is is in the other
than that in the compound of the the
phenomena saga of the left observables
of the state and that is now a
representation of G that is very similar
to what i have before mainly the action
of the symmetry on the ground states of
a half king and guess what let's see
what it is so if you'll apply this this
formula here then when we get is the
following so here if i take matrix
elements with vectors in this space so
that means that i have now something of
the form so now the a1's i need to i can
i can commute them because they're all
on the left so they they are this and if
i take a limit i'm going to get place
Rove some iteration of the maps have
been simply applied to Luigi that's
that's what this will say because but if
you want again you can take this formula
you put the a2 here then you you have a
number of times e of ug ug but that just
reproduces ug as long as I have capital
ug hit little DG is just an eigenvector
and the formula you get is this and now
this tells me there this representation
must be contained in the direct sum of
little youjizz and since these are inter
dimensional spaces must be an infinite
number of copies but there is no other
so all the matrix elements there's all
this is just a linear map this is a
linear combination of matrix elements of
little ug nothing else none of you g was
that original representation that I used
to construct the state right
a little ug is also the representation
that you find if you start over half
infinity which I argued wasn't buried so
i can calculate the matrix elements of
this representation in dismay as limits
of observers of local local local things
so it's observable in the end the chain
and a representation is a fully
determined by its matrix elements by
some whole theorem of wild the matrix
elements look like matrix elements of WG
then little DG is what it is you don't
know the multiplicity if it's in a
reducible representation this has to be
an identity fission another way if it's
a reducible representation it's not the
multiplicities may change and so also in
the case that I described you like for
the akl tomorrow in fact you get all
matrix elements so even if it's in it at
a deuce of a representation you will get
all matrix elements and you hold also
half again so in general I have identity
and it shows that let energy is there's
a verbal in the dog
and and the gradient valium okay I'm
running out of time I believe and for
them since they at the end of the story
maybe just a few comments um so as I
said there is another class of one
dimensional models for which I can prove
the same result in a different way but
of course we are all many of us I know
how did interested in two dimensions and
and then now the general soft theory
applies so if you have systems with a
boundary and you will be able to use the
representation of the symmetry on the
boundary as in a value but I don't know
how practical it will be I don't know
how to extract it from the belt and in
fact often they will often have is my
sense sort of an essential part and then
other parts and then to distinguish one
from the other I don't know exactly how
to do and then on top of everything not
only is it difficult to prove that you
have about the uniform O'Brien respect
or gap in higher dimensions it actually
may be cases where you where you done
because they are boundary excitations
that are gapless and some of the same
ideas should apply but you will be have
to invent something to overcome the
existence of gapless excitations that
sort of close a gap that really there is
somewhere a gap you could use that it's
sort of not a gap in the spectrum and
therefore a little more difficult
but I'm running over time so I'll stop
thank you know we have several breaks
basically after we talked for every
second talk so since we are leaving top
of time so i will invite everybody to
ask a question that you give me the
coffee break and to do it also during
the next text from you the coffee breaks
to us press into a speaker they are both
absolutely